- [Instructor] We're told a
yoga mat is 3/5 of a meter wide.
It has an area of 1
and 2/25 square meters.
What is the length of the mat?
Well, we know that length times width
is going to give you area,
or another way of thinking about it,
if the product of two numbers
gives you a third number,
if you take that third number
and divide it by one of these,
you're going to get the other one.
So another way of thinking about it
is length would be the same
thing as area divided by width.
So we're trying to figure
out the length here.
We have the area, we have the width.
So our length is going to be 1 and 2/25,
1 and 2/25 divided by 3/5.
Now this is going to be the same thing as,
let me write this as an improper fraction,
it's gonna be easier to do
some arithmetic with it.
So one is the same thing
as 25/25, plus 2/25,
this is 27/25 divided by 3/5.
And we've already talked
about how this is saying
how many 3/5 can fit into 27/25.
And we've given the intuition
why this is the same thing
as just multiplying 27/25
times the reciprocal of 3/5,
which is 5/3.
And so this is going to be equal to,
and actually I'm gonna
factor this out a little bit
to simplify things a bit.
27 is 3 x 3 x 3.
25 is 5 x 5.
So this is going to be equal to,
in our numerator we're
gonna have 3 x 3 x 3 x 5.
3 x 3 x 3 x 5.
And then in our denominator
we're gonna have 5 x 5 x 3.
5 x 5 x 3.
And then we can reduce this a little bit.
We can divide both the numerator
and the denominator by five.
and the denominator by three.
So in the numerator, we're
gonna 3 x 3, which is 9/5.
So this is all going to be equal to 9/5.
So the yoga mat is 3/5 of a meter wide
and 9/5 of a meter long.
Now let's make sure that this makes sense.
So I'm gonna make a grid.
So this right over here is 1/5 of a meter.
1/5 of a meter in that dimension
and 1/5 of a meter in that dimension.
And then we can see, well,
if this is 1/5 of a meter,
then the width right over
here is 3/5 of a meter.
Our length right over
here, we have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, fifths.
It is 9/5.
Now each of these units, what is its area?
Well, it is 1/25 meter squared.
And how many of these do we have?
Well, we can see, we
have three rows of nine,
which is 27 of these 25ths,
so we're gonna have 27/25 square meters,
which is the same thing as
1 and 2/5 square meters.